To test this hypothesis that lightning was actually electricity,
Benjamin Franklin did something--well, something incredibly stupid.
Now, it's not entirely certain if Franklin actually did this experiment
but what's believed is that he took a kite out into a windy, raging thunderstorm
and as the kite flew and the string got wet, well he tied a key to that string.
His thinking being that, well if this lightning is somehow electricity
there's got to be a ton of this electricity in the sky.
And so he probably didn't actually allow the kite to get struck by lightning
because that could've been fatal.
Instead, he let the kite fly close to the clouds where he hoped it would collect electricity.
That electricity he hoped will be transferred somehow along this wet kite string
into the key, which could then be touched to this--what's called an electrode
of the Leyden jar, thus charging the jar.
When he did the experiment, it worked. What he set out to do actually happened.
He showed that since lightning can be used to charge a Leyden jar,
lightning must be electricity.
For the rest of this unit, we're going to learn about electricity.
Now I have to say this is usually a subject that's covered over an entire course.
So what we're going to do here is learn the very basics enough to protect our buildings
from being struck by lightning but this is really just a teaser.
We're really just skimming the surface of what there is to learn about electricity.